There have been nearly 5,000 fires in California since the start of 2018.
The fire season has been dominating the news.
This has turned into another record-setting fire season.
Now the largest in state history.
Really there's no end in sight.
It's hot.
It's dry.
It's windy.
Just about everything on the ground is flammable,...
...but there is one thing that's consistently making wildfires in California worse...
...and worse and worse.
Us.
At this point, even calling them wildfires might be a misnomer...
...because most of them are not natural.
Humans are responsible for starting a whopping 84 percent of them.
The Northern California Carr fire, for example,...
...was started by sparks from a car tire's rim.
And in Southern California,...
...the Holy Fire just outside of LA started after a suspected arson.
These are just two of the fires currently active in the state.
So far, in 2018, 629,000 acres have burned.
That's nearly three times as much compared to the same time period in 2017.